Vérino : Un peu de pression
Fabien : Mais là il faut te concentrer
F : Salut, aujourd'hui Vérino va se concentrer
V : Ouais, c'est peut-être la première fois de ma vie que je me concentre, donc soyez bien attentifs
Concentrez vous sur ma concentration
F : Vérino c'est la première personne qui a fait une vidéo avec moi cette année
Depuis le début de l'année je donne plein de conseils sur la mémoire
Et on n'a jamais vu ce que ça donnait en live d'essayer de l'apprendre à quelqu'un
Est-ce que c'est rapide ou pas, est-ce que c'est faisable ou pas ? On se tente ça ?
V : Ouais c'est la grande question, c'est pour ça que j'ai de la pression
C'est pour ça que j'ai besoin de me concentrer, parce que j'ai pas envie de, devant tous tes abonnés,
que les gens réalisent qu'en fait je suis un tocard
F : Noon, ils sont pas nombreux
V: Non *rires*
F : Toute manière.. ouais ... ou alors je.. pour une fois je mets pas un titre putaclic et personne regardera la vidéo
La vidéo va être forcément un petit peu longue je pense que je vais accélérer des passages
Mais je vais essayer de te donner des images clés mentales, d'accord ?
V : Ok
F : associées aux chiffres de 1 à 20
F : Ouais  "Chiffres de 1 à 20 ??" ; les nombres de 1 à 20 aussi si tu veux
Alors des images clés associées aux chiffres, on va essayer de le faire soit en rimes soit avec ce qui marche le plus pour toi
Quand je te dis 1, le chiffre 1, il te fait penser à quelle image ?
V : Euh... à un Hun, un viking
F : Un viking, vraiment, avec une barbe et tout
V :  avec une grosse barbe, des cornes et tout, ouais
F : Tu sais que c'est un truc qui est utilisé souvent en mnémotechnique pour le 1
V : Ah oui ?
V : Le 2 à quoi il me ferait penser ? Le 2.. le 2.. le 2..
Je vois juste deux doigts comme ça je crois
F : D'accord, c'est pas très fort, moi je te propose de mettre du feu, deux... feu..
V : D'accord.
Parce que ça... ça t'irait ou pas ?
V : Bin ça marche très bien ouais
F : Comme ça on peut faire cramer des choses après plus tard dans sa mémoire, c'est plutôt pas mal
V : Ok, ok, ok
F : Trois ça te fait penser à quoi ? Soit par le son, soit par l'image en elle-même du 3
V : 3... une croix, c'est pas mal ça ?
F : Ouais
F : 4, c'est plus dur.
V : 4, c'est plus dur, euh.. un chat mais qui parle anglais, *meaouww*
F : Cinq, Zinc,
V : Ok
F : Six ?
V : Six euh... euh.. six..six...
Une femme enceinte c'est bien ça
F : Une femme enceinte avec la forme du 6 comme ça ?
V : Ouais
V : Euh, attends, sept, sinon qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
F : Alors je peux te proposer une tête, et dans ce cas là tu penses à quelqu'un qui n'a pas de tête justement
V : D'accord
F : Huit ?
V : Une huître, une huître !
F : Oui OK !
V : Je vais prendre
F : Une huître qu'on ouvrirait pour voir la perle
V : Voilà et qui en plus, elle aurait deux formes de rond comme ça
F : Hé pas mal
F : Neuf ?
V : Neuf, un oeuf
F : Dix ?
V : Dix.. une scisse, une scisse *rire* [scie N.D.L.R.]
F : Alors moi j'ai un flic dans un commissariat dans ma tête
V : Pourquoi ?
F : Police, mais c'est pas ma meilleure image
V : Non c'est vrai que... mais c'est ton image, c'est toi qui l'a choisie
F : Ok j'ai un peu la pression je t'avoue mais, ça te va dix, police ?
V : Ouais, dix, police, ok
F : OK, on va à vingt ou pas ?
V : Ouais
F : Onze, j'ai penseur de Rodin, comme ça
V : Parce qu'il est en bronze ?
F : Exactement
V : Ok
F : Douze, j'ai de la pelouse, mais pas n'importe laquelle, celle que j'avais dans ma première maison
Donc c'est-à-dire, si tu prends la pelouse en douze, il faut que ce soit une pelouse que tu connais
un jardin en fait, au delà de la pelouse, tu vois ?
V : La pelouse des vacances de la petite maison de campagne
F : Je croyais qu'on allait pas le savoir, c'est la pelouse où j'ai enterré mon meilleur ami y'a deux jours
*rires*
F : Euh treize ?
V : La mauvaise nouvelle c'est que du coup t'es pas mon meilleur ami
Ou alors la vidéo sortira deux jours après ta mort et on se dira " Il est où Olicard ?"
F : On ne sait pas..
V : Y'a un indice quelque part dans une vidéo
V : Euh.. treize moi j'ai baise donc j'ai un couple qui est en train de.. de procréer ça te va
F : D'accord
V : Quatorze, un 1 et un 4, est-ce qu'on remettrait pas le bateau avec un mât en plus où y'a pas de voile ?
F : Ça peut être un homme sur la planche à voile, moi j'ai un sucre d'orge
V : Ok, ben le crabe on part sur le crabe
V : Seize... j'ai un couple qui baise *rire*
Non là on va mettre une fraise
V : Comme ça c'est intéressant, ça peut être perturbant, je me mets des petits défis
F : Ça marche
V : Ouais moi j'appellerais la police en fait là pour le coup
Mais le problème c'est que police on l'avait déjà dit pour six
Chaussette alors, vendu pour chaussette.
F : Chaussette ?
V : Ouais
F : Ok
V : Je te ferai le chemin vers la police puis des chaussettes, donc j'aurai un flic en chaussettes
V : Dix-huit euh.. dix-huit.. dix-huit.. dix-huit
F : Moi je te propose un slip
V : Tu proposes quoi toi ?
F : Un slip.
V : Un slip ? Ok
F : Dix-neuf ?
V : Euh, dix-neuf, moi j'ai dans mon panier neuf, du coup ce sera pas ça
Oh si, un panier neuf c'est bien ça
F : Et en vingt ?
V : *bruit de dégustation*
F : Tu peux prendre le verre de la bouteille
F : Donc, là..
V : C'est la fin de cette vidéo, merci de l'avoir regardée *rire*
F : En douze minutes, enfin en moins de douze minutes parce qu'on a parlé au départ
En douze minutes Vérino a construit et appris une table de rappel de 0 à 20
V : Ne faîtes pas ça chez vous !
F : Maintenant on va voir si tu es capable de t'en servir
F : Donc je vais te donner 20 mots
V : Ok
F : et tu vas les mémoriser dans ta tête de 1 à 20
F : Et pour les mémoriser tu vas associer le mot que je te donne avec l'image que t'as en tête
Tu vas essayer de faire les images les plus marquantes possibles
Si par exemple je te donnais un casque en 1, faudra surtout pas que t'imagines ton Hun avec un casque de Hun
parce que tu l'oublierais, par contre avec un casque de moto et sur une moto directement, là ça tiendrait mieux
V : Je crois que ça s'est vu à l'écran qu'en vrai c'est ce que j'allais faire d'avoir le casque
et je me disais c'est bien c'est le casque
F : Allez je te propose en 1, euh.. un pneu de voiture
V : Un pneu de voiture..
F : J'ai même pas réfléchi aux mots que j'allais te donner en fait
*rire général*
F : Un téléphone portable
V : Un téléphone portable, Ok.
V : Donc un Samsung ® a priori
F : Ouais
V : En 3, un perroquet, euh.. d'accord.
F : En 4 , je vais te demander d'imaginer un extincteur
V : Ok
F : Puis-je te demander l'image du 4 ?
V : Alors c'est une planche à voile avec un extincteur allumé et du coup elle va plus vite
F : D'accord ça c'est pas mal
V + F : Ouais
V : *bruit de planche ??!?*
F : Je pense que j'aurais imaginé le mec qui fait de la planche à voile sur de la mousse
Et qu'en fait la mousse était faite par l'extincteur, mais on est sur les mêmes principes de grossir, grossir
et de faire n'importe quoi
V : Ok, en 5, une moto, ok
F : C'est bon ?
V : Ouais
*passage accéléré*
F : Bon, eh bé maintenant on va voir si ça fonctionne, euh.. une méthode
et est-ce que ça vaut le coup de passer les 12 minutes de départ à avoir une table de rappel
pour après essayer d'apprendre des choses par cœur
V : La réponse évidemment.. *petit rire*
F : Alors quand je te demande, maintenant je vais te donner les numéros un peu dans le désordre
V : Ouais
F : Tu me donnes pas ton image de table de rappel mais celle...
V : Je te donne le mot que tu m'as donné
F : Admettons qu'en fait t'essayais de retenir un discours, un numéro de téléphone ou de ce genre de choses
Tu vois c'est ça que je veux voir si t'arrives à t'en servir, quoi
En 12 on avait ?
V : On avait un manteau
F : Exact !
F : En 5 ?
V : En 5 on avait une moto
F : Yes ! En 7 ?
V : En 7 on n'avait rien
F : Yes ! En 14 ?
V : En 14.. on avait.. pu***n il me fait ch**r celui-là
14.. c'est les lunettes
F : Yes !
F : En  11 on avait ?
V : En 11 on avait euh... .. .. on l'a pas fait celui-là !?
F : Exact mais je t'ai pas prévenu
V : Mais oui, *rire*, petit coquin !
F : Je te donne les mots et t'essayes de dire ça c'était rangé en telle case, tu vois ?
V : D'accord
F : Cheveux ?
V : Cheveux.. c'est 16 !
F : Yes !
F : En.. perroquet ?
V : Perroquet.. c'est le 3 !
F : Yes !
F : Les lunettes ?
V : Les lunettes c'est c'est.. le sucre d'orge, le 14 !
F : Oui et le moulin à vent ?
V : Et le moulin à vent c'est le 13 !
F : Yes !
F : T'essayes de tous les restituer d'un coup ?
V : Ouais
F : Et en partant de la fin.
V : En partant de la fin évidemment
V : Alors, en 20 c'est une table.
F : Correct !
V : En 19, c'est un canard.
F : Oui !
V : En 18, c'est.. 18.. 18.. 18..
F : Tu cherches ta table ou .. ?
V : Je cherche tout, c'est vraiment...
Ouais je cherche la table, 18 c'est...
F : Et vous voyez le 18 c'est vraiment l'image qui n'est pas venu de lui au départ, un truc que je lui ai donné
il l'a pris tout de suite
V : C'est l'or, le chauffage
F : Exact.
F : 17 ?
V : 17, c'est la brosse à dents
F : Oui !
V : 16, c'est.. des cheveux !
F : Est-ce qu'on l'avait déjà dit ?
V : On avait déjà dit 16 ?
F : Est-ce qu'on l'avait déjà fait ou pas une fois ?
V : Tout à l'heure, ouais.
F : Ouais
V : Enfin dans le premier truc
F : Donc on l'a déjà fait
F : C'est pour montrer aussi qu'on a une mémoire de ce qu'on a repassé ou pas comme image
V : Ouais c'est vrai
V : Et le 15, est-ce qu'on l'avait déjà fait ?
Le 15 est-ce qu'on l'avait déjà fait ?
Euh.., non on l'avait pas déjà fait.
Et le 15 c'est donc.. du vin !
*passage accéléré*
V : 1, c'est un casque de moto. Non ! ça c'est un truc que tu m'as dit, du coup on l'a pas fait en vrai !
F : C'était un petit piège
V : Bien ouèj
F : .. que je t'ai préparé pour la fin, et maintenant faut que t'ailles quand même chercher la vraie image
V : Euh.. que j'aille quand même chercher la vraie image ?
F : Ouais
V : Ah oui, bah c'est le hun, c'est le viking.
F : Oui, mais c'est quoi qu'on a mis ?
V : Ah, on a vraiment mis quelque chose ? Ok.
Alors en 1, on a dû mettre, un pneu !
F : Exact
V : Évidemment
F : Et ça c'était pour vous faire voir qu'on peut écraser une table de rappel avec un autre objet
Mais il faut qu'on ait une image bien forte pour pouvoir virer l'autre
V : P**n c'est fort !
V : En quatre minutes, on a réussi à retenir tout, haa héé, ça va
F : Han Héé, pas mal
F : Tiens je te laisse le papier
V : Merci beaucoup
F : Le lis pas, le regarde pas, mais surprends toi demain..
V : D'accord
F : .. à te dire, tiens je vais essayer de le refaire.
Tu le donnes à ta femme, et tu lui demandes qu'elle t'interroge
Y'en a qui vont virer, les moins forts
V : Écoute c'est dingue, parce que en vrai, je suis arrivé en me disant "je vais échouer"
Je vais vraiment pas vous mentir, je suis arrivé en me disant :
"C'est bien, ça va être une vidéo marrante, où Fabien Olicard va me montrer que je suis un teubé"
Et j'étais sûr de ça, donc je suis vraiment pour le coup, même encore plus bluffé que sur la première vidéo qu'on avait faite
F : Bah oui parce que..
V : Sur la première vidéo j'étais en action et tout ça..
F : Tu révèles toi même ce que tu es et ce que tu peux faire, et ce qu'on t'as toujours fais croire
que tu ne savais pas faire
V : Exactement
F : La plupart des gens, même quand je donnais des formations ou quoi,
disaient " oui mais c'est très long, du coup, comme processus, à apprendre..."
C'est moins long que d'essayer d'apprendre les choses par cœur
V : Oui c'est ça. En fait tu fais ton détour
C'est comme quand t'es sur Google Maps
Et qu'il te dit "tout droit, y'a 10 minutes de bouchons",
mais si tu fais ça, tu vas bizarrement économiser du temps
Mais c'est vrai.
F : Et du carburant, parce que du coup ça va te tenir extrêmement longtemps
V : Ah
F : *Inaudible*
V : C'est Philou qui appelle
F : Merci Philippe Roche !
F : Placement de produit Philippe Roche
V : T'es vraiment une putaclic
F : Ah ouais, hé c'est incroyable ça
V : En vrai, j'aimerais bien dire que tous les gens de cette vidéo, si jamais vous avez envie de venir
sur ma chaîne à moi, tous les gens qui ont tendance à écrire des trucs débiles en commentaires
Ne venez pas ! Vous ne m'intéressez pas, j'ai pas du tout envie de vous parler
F : Ça c'est marrant, parce qu'on a eu une discussion à ce sujet, c'est rigolo ça, hein ?
V : C'est fou !
F : C'est très très marrant
F : Et tous les autres, je vous invite à découvrir Vérino si vous ne connaissez pas
Il met une vidéo tous les samedis matin à 11h qui s'appelle "Dis donc Internet"
Il filme ça en public à la fin de son spectacle, avec le public derrière, c'est pas un fond vert
V : Ouais, je tourne le vendredi soir, alors y'en a qui vont se poser des questions
de savoir déjà, si c'est un fond vert, de 2,  "est-ce que tu fais tout ton spectacle de dos ?"
Bah évidemment *rire*
Évidemment je vais jouer pendant une heure comme ça, avec des gens qui me regardent
F : En fait c'est The Voice, c'est lui qui décide si il se retourne ou pas
F : J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, et surtout qu'elle va vous motiver, vous aussi,
à vous servir de votre mémoire un peu différemment
Rappelez vous qu'il y a une playlist qui concerne tous les trucs de mémoire,
je vous la remettrai dans la description
Si vous avez aimé, n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en mettant un petit "poutce" en l'air
"Poutce"
V : Yeah, youdouboudou les petites poutces
F : Pouce en l'air ! Vous pouvez également vous abonner à ma chaîne
Découvrir celle de Vérino également en cliquant ici et ici, ça va être à peu près par là
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !
V : Ciao !